- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
Welcome to
the "The Super Slow Show."
- We're at the drop zone.
- Yes, we are.
That means we're
about to drop something.
It might just be this car.
Yeah, this is from
the catapult video.
Right.
We couldn't sell it,
and we thought it's not
sufficiently trashed enough.
We definitely
dented it up.
- Yeah.
- But it's not annihilated.
It's not
completely crushed.
Dan:  Oh!
Gav:  Right through the zero.
-  Oh, God!
-  That was so clean.
So we've got
a 40-ton crane,
and we're gonna lift it
about 80 feet up into the air.
Wonder what speed
it's gonna go when
it hits the floor.
That is up there.
It really is.
We're going to be getting
this on two Phantoms,
one that's wide,
a thousand frames,
one a little bit tighter,
2,000 frames a second.
We've also got a GoPro
in the back,
looking forwards.
And another one
on this fat hook.
This is the biggest hook
I've ever seen.
- It's massive.
- Massive.
We also thought
that an impact into the dirt
would be too soft,
so we've replaced the floor
with, like, an inch of steel.
So this should be horrendous.
( theme music playing )
( crane whirring )
Well, it's definitely something
we couldn't do in your back
garden, for sure.
Absolutely not.
That crane just lifted it
like it was nothing.
It's like, all right,
here we go, 80 feet.
It's absolutely dwarfed
the ruler.
Imagine being
in the front seat,
how scary that would be.
- You wouldn't live.
There's no way.
- No, there's no way.
- All right.
- Although, I reckon
that when it hits,
the car's going to come
forwards towards the Phantom
- because of the way it is.
- All right.
I'm really looking
forward to this.
- You wanna get it going?
- I'm ready.
All right.
Three! Two! One! Drop!
Oh! Oh!
( laughing )
That was just
a little bounce.
Yeah.
At one point it hit the floor.
I think it was in mid-air again.
Gav: I think,
if there's an area,
where it's, like,
back off the ground again.
Wow. Oh, we smashed
the windows, though.
We got more points.
Should we go check it out?
Yeah.
- Oh.
- Look at this.
- ( gasps )
- You can still see the
100-point marks on the window.
It fell out perfectly.
Look, it's just laid out,
Dan:
And the GoPro's still
attached to it.
I think the only way
you could've done that
is to drop a car
from a crane.
I think you're right.
I absolutely think you're right.
Gav:
Oh, that is a flat front.
Dan:
Oh, man, that is squished.
'Cause that's not like hitting
a car, where it's uneven.
That just absolutely
crushed it.
Oh, man.
Sound guy's definitely not
gonna be pleased this time.
I mean, at least last time
you could drive it afterwards.
This, I think,
is unsalvageable.
I'd just say
it's more breezy.
Gav:  Crunch.
Dan:  Oh, look at the ripple
go all along the...
It just drives
into itself.
Look at the dust
it kicked out
from the front.
It's, like, wafted
all the dust away.
Oh, look, the mirror.
The million points
has gone flying.
You can see one mirror...
What are the chances?
- Dan:  Oh, close-up.
- Gav:  This is satisfying.
Glad we got
that metal there.
-  Yeah, that's solid.
-  That tin-foil effect again.
-  On the hard metal.
-  Oh, look.
-  The mirror hit the car
and then flung out
-  It popped out.
-  Yeah.
-  It was like a catapult.
That's amazing.
So then it took off.
How high did it even get?
It must've been,
like, an inch.
That's--
I like that I'm leaning down
to try and see under.
Yeah, I did the same.
You beat me there.
Nope, that's
completely useless.
Idiots.
Oh, we get to see
the window smash.
See, there's
the side door.
-  See?
-  Yeah, the side
smashed off as well.
-  Lovely.
-  So I think we should
destroy it even more.
-  All right.
-  All right,
should we flip it over?
Yeah, let's flip it over and
we'll destroy it some more.
If you could open the doors,
which you can't,
there's also enough room
to actually sit in there.
- That's not good enough.
- Definitely not good enough.
- I think we should change that.
What have you got in mind?
Ta-da. This guy
is a concrete K-rail,
weighs about
3 1/2 metric tons,
in English, so--
What's that in American?
About 8,000 pounds.
Ooh, what's that in stone?
- Wait, 8,000 divided by 14.
- We haven't got time for this.
- Yeah.
- So, I think drop it
on the roof lengthways,
and see how much carnage
we can cause,
'cause I wanna completely
finish this thing off.
- All right.
- Yeah?
- Let's hoist 'er up.
- Cool.
So you don't often see
a roof-on collision, do you?
It's either a head-on or
a fender bender or a side--
So this is simulating
a plane nose-diving
into the roof of a car.
With a concrete block on it
for some reason.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. You ready?
Let's turn this thing
into a pancake.
- Dan: Cool.
- Or a hot dog.
Three, two, one, drop!
- Oh...
- That is beefy.
The deep bassy thud.
That has smushed the car.
Can you hear it hissing?
Should we get in there?
- Yeah.
- Let's check it out.
Ah, the delicious hiss
of the Freon.
Oh, man.
You would have to get
into some serious trouble
for your car
to look like that.
I mean, it's certainly
popped the tires.
- It popped all the tires.
- I'm not sure if they were
already popped.
I don't think
I've ever seen a car
more annihilated
than this,
unless you're talking
like that's been crushed
at a scrappy.
Yeah, one that's cubed.
Yeah, this is the most
crushed and smushed
a car has ever been
that I've seen.
Almost sad.
Sound guy will be sad.
That's for sure.
All right, let's go
look at the footage.
That just looks so wrong.
It's going so fast.
A concrete rail should not be
in the air like that.
- Dan:  Whoa.
- Gav:  You see all the dust
get kicked up?
Dan:  Oh, man.
All the tires popped.
Everything just smushed.
Gav:  Even the air being forced
out through the windows
is significant,
like you see, like a...
( imitates air whooshing )
That car probably weighs a
metric ton and a half, maybe.
That K-rail is more than twice
the weight of the car,
a much smaller surface area.
And then you can see--
because obviously the engine
is the hardest part.
The other end, the back end,
went all the way down.
Any air that was
in the car
is now out and gone.
Like, there's
no space in there.
That's beautiful
and horrific.
Some people pay a lot of money
to lower their cars.
All you need to do is drop
a concrete block on it.
- Yeah.
- Look at it.
I mean, you say that
like this was cheap,
like this was
the cheap version.
Good point.
Way more expensive
to do it like this.
Fair enough, yeah.
Hopefully you enjoyed
that mindless destruction.
Feel free to subscribe
to the Slow Mo Guys
and we'll see you
in a future episode
of "The Super Slow Show"
where we'll probably break
something again.
Hi, guys, we can't wait
to share
our extremely slow
adventure with you.
Yeah, click here
for all the latest updates
happening almost daily
on "The Super Slow Show."
Why do they put
the button on this side?
It could easily have
just been just there,
but it's on
this side of me.
It's like somewhere
around here.
Yeah,
it's right there.
( chuckles )